[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'a volatiles dame viser un
grand café crème légère 3,3 sur verdon
way avait redonné partie sportive
interpellé crème un verre d'eau bon
confort à des 4èmes un bardeau étape
vous avez une ordonnance ya plus de
tartines voulez une autre côte longue
es6 aller à vous voulez un bout de cake
non qu'est ce que vous allez prendre ça
s'est passé pourquoi ces chiffres nous
non non vous voulez que je vous parle un
petit peu non
pas du tout ça va vous en ce moment non
non non parce que moi j'ai déjà des
problèmes là j'ai jemma machine il a été
pris en grippe par une grille par les
clippers et puis chamkhi peu inquiet
parce que ça fait quand même huit jours
que la balle était à l'école ça il est
venu le médecin il est venu mais on
n'était pas là non il était sorti quand
il est bien fait oui parce qu'on avait
une soirée avec des copains dans une
boîte échangiste
on était au fond du club et des soirées
lundi vous connaissez et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous il m'était impossible ou